vamos a aproximar el área que está por
debajo de la gráfica de la función f x
igual a x al cuadrado más 1 que queda
entre los puntos 1 y 3 y para esto lo
que vamos a hacer es construir 4
rectángulos que queden por debajo de la
gráfica y que tengan el mismo largo
vamos a pensar cómo se verían salen
entonces el primer rectángulo llegaría
más o menos por acá llegaría como a esta
altura bueno a este a este lugar del
intervalo el segundo rectángulo llegaría
más o menos por aquí ahorita no me estoy
concentrando en sus alturas sale ahorita
pasamos a eso pero primero déjame nada
más ver cómo serían de largo entonces
ahí ahí van dos este sería el tercero el
tercero y este que queda hasta acá sería
el cuarto rectángulo entonces lo primero
que vamos a pensar es cuando tendrían
que tener de base para que todos
tuvieran el mismo largo va entonces a
esa base vamos a ponerle delta de x como
le haríamos para calcular delta de x a
pues delta de x va a ser igual a todo lo
que se recorre en este intervalo
a tres menos uno que es dos dividido
entre la cantidad de rectángulos que
queremos que son cuatro rectángulos esto
sería igual a dos cuartos pero es lo
mismo que un medio entonces delta de x
es igual a un medio y por lo tanto
podemos saber cuáles son los extremos de
los intervalos que marcamos acá abajo
verdad el primer rectangular el primer
rectángulo idea de 1 a 1.5 el segundo
rectángulo iría de 1.5 a 2 el tercer
rectángulo iría de 2 a 2.5 que
terminaría en 2.5 y ahí empezaría el
cuarto y último rectángulo que va de 2.5
a 3 2.5 3 es la base de este último
recta muy bien ahora si vamos a pensar
en la altura en el transcurso de estos
vídeos vamos a ver que hay varias formas
de definir las alturas de estos
rectángulos para hacer una aproximación
pero ahorita para agarrar una en
concreto lo que vamos a hacer es
utilizar la función evaluada en el
extremo izquierdo de cada intervalo para
definir cuál va a ser la altura de los
rectángulos
déjame hacerlo para que veamos a qué me
refiero por ejemplo para este primer
rectángulo su intervalo es de 1 a 1.5
entonces su altura va a estar definida
por la función evaluada en 1 que es el
extremo izquierdo entonces llegaría aquí
porque justo la gráfica nos indica dónde
dónde o bueno cuál cuál es el valor de
la función en este punto entonces el
rectángulo se vería más o menos a ciudad
tengamos un rectángulo de esta forma
pasemos al segundo rectángulo aquí en el
segundo rectángulo su altura su altura
sería f de 1.5 que queda más o menos por
acá le voy a poner
efe de 1.5 y justo a esta altura
tendríamos el segundo rectángulo
entonces llegaría aquí y vamos a marcar
su lado derecho el segundo rectángulo es
este de acá muy bien pasemos al tercer
rectángulo creo que ya veis más o menos
cómo está la cosa verdad el tercer
rectángulo para ver cuánto sería su
altura pues nos fijamos en efe del
extremo izquierdo y aquí el extremo
izquierdo es 2 entonces su altura sería
efe de 2 vale entonces tendríamos este
rectángulo de acá de este rectángulo
color rosa mexicano rosa mexicano y
finalmente el cuarto y último rectángulo
tendría altura
efe de 2.5 efe de 2.5 entonces por aquí
por aquí llegaría el rectángulo
y se vería más o menos así vale entonces
aquí estoy sombreando el área de el
cuarto rectángulo muy bien entonces lo
que hicimos fue fijarnos en el extremo
izquierdo para determinar las alturas
ahora si este cuánto sería la
aproximación del área utilizando estos
rectángulos de acá y ojo pues sí es una
aproximación nada más verdad no es el
área exacta porque no es el área exacta
pues porque estamos regalando tantos
cachitos de área mira este cachito de
acá no lo estamos considerando este de
acá tampoco lo estamos considerando y
este de acá tampoco si entonces esos
cuatro cachitos sobran y por tanto
nuestra aproximación es una aproximación
por abajo no porque sea por debajo de la
curva sino porque es una aproximación
menor al área que queremos bueno ahora
sí cuánto sería esa aproximación pues
tendríamos que sumar el área de los
rectángulos entonces vamos a calcular el
área de cada uno y sumar
y entonces el área del primer rectángulo
pues su altura es f1
y su largo es un medio que es delta de x
le voy a poner aquí delta de equis para
entonces es la altura por la base
eso es el área de un rectángulo a eso le
vamos a sumar el área del segundo
rectángulo su altura es f de 1.5 y su
base es delta de x vamos con el tercero
aquí el tercero el tercero su altura
sería f 2
efe de 2 y eso hay que multiplicarlo por
delta equis y finalmente hay que sumar
el área del cuarto rectángulo su extremo
izquierdo es 2.5 por lo tanto la altura
es f de 2.5
efe de 2.5 y eso hay que multiplicarlo
por el largo que sería delta de x muy
bien recuerda esto de acá simplemente es
un área aproximada me voy a poner aquí
que es área
aproximada
este es un área aproximada vamos a ver
cuánto nos da vamos a evaluar utilizando
la función y utilizando este delta de x
este delta de equis de acá entonces
cuánto es f de 1 pues si ponemos 1 aquí
arriba nos queda 1 al cuadrado que es
uno más uno o sea 2 2 x un medio que por
un medio y luego tenemos
efe de 1.5 por delta x entonces sería
más a ver f de 1.5 cuanto da 1.5 al
cuadrado pues pensemos en 15 al cuadrado
15 al cuadrado de 225 recorriendo el
punto decimal nos queda a 2.25 y más
este 1 nos queda 3.25 y hay que
multiplicar por delta x que es un medio
luego más vamos con el tercer sumando 2
al cuadrados 415 nos quedaría 5 por
delta equis que vale un medio está bueno
esto verdad de que delta x sea siempre
lo mismo
más efe de 2.5 a 2.5 al cuadrado otra
vez pensemos mejor en 25 por 25 que 625
recorremos el punto decimales 6.25 más
este uno es 7.25 7.25 y hay que
multiplicar por delta x que es un medio
muy bien cuánto nos da esto de acá pues
ve todos tienen un medio un medio un
medio y un medio entonces lo que voy a
hacer para para no andar este dividiendo
entre dos tantas veces es factorizar ese
un medio y él está ya voy a utilizar
este color neutral vale para no andar
cambiando tanto y que nos quedaría nos
quedaría un medio un medio multiplicado
por dos más 3.25 más 5
mas 7.25 7.25 muy bien déjame ver si
puedo hacer esto mentalmente a ver 2 con
5 son 7 y llevamos 7 luego 3 con 7 son
10 van 17 y estos punto 25 nos juntan
1.5 entonces queda un medio de 17.572 y
5 7 3 y 7 10 van 17 y se juntan 1.5 muy
bien y cuánto es la mitad de 17.5 pues
es 8.75 muy bien entonces aquí ya
tenemos un valor ya tenemos un numerito
que nos da una aproximación y es una
aproximación inferior o una aproximación
por debajo no porque quede por debajo de
la curva otra vez sino porque es un
numerito que es menor que el área porque
hay cachitos de área que no estamos
considerando sale en los siguientes
vídeos lo que vamos a hacer es
generalizar esta idea ya no nos vamos a
fijar únicamente en fx igual
al cuadrado 1 sino que ahora vamos a
tomar una función arbitraria una
cantidad arbitraria de rectángulos en un
intervalo arbitrario y después no sólo
vamos a cambiar eso sino que además ya
no vamos a tomar rectángulos cuya altura
es el extremo izquierdo o bueno la
función evaluada en el extremo izquierdo
sino también va a ser la función
evaluada en el extremo derecho o en el
punto medio o incluso pueden ser cosas
más rocas por ejemplo podemos aproximar
el área con trapecio pero bueno hasta
entonces diviértete y nos vemos hasta la
próxima